it's hard not to be red down there in
that state
you know what we heard the story the
other day right about gronk and
uh gronk was telling the story about you
know oh he's in new england shape he's
not in florida shape
that that's real you florida that heat
getting used to that sun
there is something to that and it it can
be exhausting um so
he might be permanently red from from
here on out
okay so the idea to get to actually you
know the substance of the comments
instead of
the the fact that bruce arians is the
same color as his hat and his sweatshirt
um this whole calling out tom brady
we saw it from week one when brady had
multiple interceptions against the
saints
and bruce arians wasn't afraid to say so
after the game
and the next day which throws were
brady's fault
and it was jarring to us because
that's something that bill belichick
never
does publicly right he'll rip you in the
film room right
he's not gonna rip you publicly he was
all about protecting his guys and
and i look i'm just being honest
is the ultimate passive-aggressive
license
to insult someone you know uh
yeah whatever like when you say to me
you look tired oh you're i'm just being
honest yeah you're also being a butthole
yes i mean
there is an element of overt insult
in telling someone the truth is a whole
seinfeld episode
uh devoted to telling someone the truth
i'm just telling you the truth
you're ugly i you know i mean it's what
do you do
how do you so there's discretion there's
tact
there's diplomacy and you know bruce
erin's
never been that way and it worked that's
the thing we thought it would make tom
brady upset
to brady's credit he didn't get his nose
bent out of joint over it chris he just
dealt with it no
definitely i mean you know brady didn't
know what he was signing up for i'm sure
you know bruce arians is famous for his
ability to relate to quarterbacks and be
their buddies
and just relate to players in general
his communication
and the way he is there that's that's
what some of the things you always hear
about first with bruce arians
you know and then of course his his
offensive genius and all that
so you know he's got a great way of yeah
you know telling you you did something
bad and doing that but getting his arm
around you
and doing that as well and also within
it you know i do think he showed like
hey we're not just going to bow to brady
it's not just we're a team and we're all
getting better
and we're not just going to be like oh
he didn't do good so we're going to
change the way we play just so he can do
good
even though the team might not actually
benefit from that and that's where i
give him credit
and to me that's where him and leftwich
were special this year
as far as they never they kept pushing
him
hey you know stand in the pocket throw
the deep balls down the field
and you know in new england i felt like
they always they kind of wanted him to
do that and were trying to force that
but then they might have not been happy
with the results and they were just like
oh let's get back to all our short
throws he can do that and do it
and i think tampa was like we're out we
don't have any more short throws this is
it
this is not our offense so here you can
have those few ones
but really you're gonna have to change
to us and i think that brady didn't have
that wiggle room and the fact that they
stayed steadfast on that really helped
their team to get here where they are
now
and ultimately what bruce arians does
because you know you
the way you were explaining it as you
were saying it i'm thinking
i don't believe bruce arians really
engages in that level of analysis he
just is who he is yeah i think
that's the right way to say it it's not
i'm just being honest it's i'm being
authentic this is who i am i will tell
you
if you screw up that's how i'm going to
coach you i'm not going to mince words
publicly
if you make a mistake you're going to
hear about it through a press conference
and
hey don't make the mistake and you won't
hear about it
but he's always been true to himself and
that is admirable in and of itself there
are too many people in this world who
aren't true to who they are and bruce
ahrens has had a fantastic journey
people always say what do you root for i
root for a great story
and bruce arians is a great story they
did a football life on him if you
haven't seen it i'm sure you can find it
somewhere go watch it not right now
they'll keep watching us you can watch
you watch it later um but you know a guy
who became a coach head coach
after he was retired by the steelers i
mean the steelers
fired him but called it a retirement he
lands in indianapolis
with chuck pagano after he was
involuntarily retired by the steelers
becomes coach of the year that season
because pagano missed a lot of time
as he fought leukemia and then aryans
gets his reward he becomes coach of the
cardinals he's there five years
retires again doesn't like it this time
he did retire
didn't like tv wanted to coach again and
look what he's fallen into
it's incredible you know this is a guy
who was done twice
once because he wanted to be in once
because he didn't want to be
and now he's stepped into a super bowl
team
it's incredible it's it's an incredible
capper
on a great coaching story it is it's
it's like hard not to root for him you
almost feel like a little bit like andy
reid last year where you just go
and man i want to root for him because
of all the great things he's done
the way he treats people it's just all
top notch and that's the same thing with
bruce arians
that's why they are easy to root for for
that from for that aspect
and he does deserve a lot of credit you
know it really does i mean not
easy to to mold this many personalities
make the move they made from jameis
winston to tom brady
you know having the deal and and you
know bridge that gap and all of those
things uh
just a phenomenal job really the staff
he acquired there
really good you know him jason light who
we
probably haven't talked about as a
really quality awesome gm and the team
he's built here and
given him enough credit you know there's
a lot a lot of good to talk about
there in tampa but very happy that bruce
arians is getting his due justice here
i wrote something about light over the
weekend it dawned on me wait a minute
he's the one that put together this team
that was sufficiently attractive
to tom brady yeah when you look at the
receivers that he's drafted when you
look at the defense
they've put together you know levante
david is one of the few guys that jason
light inherited in 2014
well yeah he you know he drafted jameis
winston well it's not like marcus
mariota became peyton manning
and and they they weren't uh you know
adamant about sticking with jameis
winston if bruce arians doesn't want him
light's gonna move on from him and you
know the roberto aguayo thing oh that's
a black mark on the resume well every
gm's got a black mark on his resume
look at the team that they have right
now right the skill position players
they have right now the willingness
to go for it antonio brown's available
right
the packers maybe made a phone call the
buccaneers
went for it leonard fournette's
available right the buccaneers
went for it right and i know that that
isn't
the ideal way to build a team that's
going to contend for 10 years
but you can build a team that's going to
contend for 10 years and never get to a
super bowl or you can go for it
and get to a super bowl and that's what
jason light has done
and you know if you convince brady to
stick around for a few more years
they're going to be in the conversation
i think for as long as brady's there
chris no doubt i mean
they've built it's you know we've we've
talked about it all year
again you know i'm not trying to pat
each other on the back here but
it's it is one of the most talented
teams in football it it is
really impressive i watched cam jordan
last night on tv go
oh they put up the weapons of the chiefs
and the the tampa bay buccaneers because
he played both teams this year
and he went no i think the bucks have
better weapons than the chiefs
so that just says a lot let alone oh
sue oh vita v vida veya excuse me
jpp free agent signing oh shaquille
barrett value free agent signing what he
leads the nfl in
sacks his first year there the donovan
smith draft pick
tristan wurfs people weren't sure about
him at the tackle position
killed it was probably the best rookie
tackle in the draft
from last year as far as how he played
so jason light i got a lot of respect
for him
i really do i worked with him a little
in new england uh i'm not shocked
to see him here where he is now he
doesn't i don't think he likes me
anymore because when i used to do the
draft live at bleacher report
uh when he drafted robert aguayo in the
second round i gave it a
a k for my grade um it was worse than an
f i gave it a k for kicker because i
don't grade kickers and i feel like he
hasn't talked to me since but
i don't care still awesome job by him
well
maybe you've redeemed yourself today
maybe
some real authentic praise not phony not
fake at all and that's
that's what we have in common with bruce
erin's because i think back over the
year we've called bruce out for calling
out tom brady right i don't think you
have a problem with it i don't think he
has a problem with people being who they
are
because that's who he's been and
everyone try to be who
you are hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports